[Music]
John Stamos is fully immersing himself
in his role as an honorary Jonas the
fuller house star has been involved in
an epic prank war with Nick Jonas for
months now more on that later but the
guys will decide their differences for
one night at Ellie's Wango Tango concert
on Saturday the 55 year old posed with
Joe Nick and Kevin rocking a Jonas
Brothers t-shirt John shared the pic on
Instagram with the caption hashtag uncle
Jonas the band's official insta the same
pic writing uncle Jonas welcome to the
family but the best part of this pic
takes an eagle-eye zoom in on Jon's arm
and you'll see big tattoos of Nick Joe
and Kevin spaces yeah that prank war
ain't over John actually introduced the
band before their way in go tango
performance check it out pictures of a
Jonas Brother t-shirt and because I
looked so damn good in it the guys made
me an honorary member of the band last
night is a very private ceremony I was
knighted into the band as uncle Jonas
Jon has seemingly been a fan of the guys
for a long time now and has been spotted
rocking Jonas Brothers t-shirts a lot
even on the red carpet at the 2018
American Music Awards let's talk about
your t-shirt tonight Jon are you wearing
a Jonas Brothers t-shirt
then pick anyone would know it from my
choices is that a good one
are you there did you buy the second
hand on eBay I am the fourth Jonas
brother somewhere no I got it there is a
fourth proneness Jonas you know he'd be
the fifth brought Jonas brother I love
those guys
well John may not have thought anyone
would notice but Nick did and in
February he kicked off the prank war
when he was photographed wearing a
sweatshirt that had a pic on it of John
wearing a Joe Broz tee
make sure the shot on Instagram with the
caption it's your move at John Stamos
John was fast to fire back taking things
even further with this pic that's John
laying on a pillow with a pic of Nick
wearing the t-shirt with a pic of John
whoa inception much well it didn't stop
there Nick then made a blanket out of
the image of John sleeping on his pillow
John escalated the prank war posting
this pic of him getting a fake tattoo of
Nick's face on his arm he captioned the
shot quote Joe Broz for life well it
looks like John might have a little
competition now on Sunday Joe posted
this shot from Wango Tango posing with
Ryan Seacrest and Marilyn Manson the
caption hi we are the Jonas Brothers and
you're watching Disney Channel hmm
something tells me John has nothing to
worry about
of course we'll be here to keep you up
to date on all things Jonas Brothers
including all the things we learn from
their new Amazon Prime documentary
chasing happiness that drops on Tuesday
so be sure to keep it locked on ET until
next time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for
now